imagine just for a second that you were
the one going head-to-head with boris
johnson at the dispatch box today what
would you ask about now the obvious
option is partygate all but one of
kiyosama's 18 questions over the past
three weeks have been on that subject
but today the labour leader changed tack
to tax
surely even this prime minister doesn't
need someone else to tell him that he
and the chancellor having to raise taxes
because the tories failed to grow the
economy over a decade today he's
ordering his troops to vote for tax cuts
for banks now i've spoken to some of
kiesdama's team they say the reason they
chose tax is because it's a real source
of pain for tory backbenchers they do
not like it and therefore conservatives
sitting there
in the chamber were less likely to
heckle kierstama now we've analyzed some
of the words the labour leader used
today words that appeared a lot tax and
taxes as well as working people popped
up boris johnson's response as ever was
to go on the attack attack labour's
economic record in government even
though of course that ended nearly 12
years ago
labour never forget mr speaker there's
never been a labor government that left
office with unemployment lower than when
they are when they were in office mr
speaker when they were finally booted
out they left a note saying there's no
money left that's the way that's the way
they run the country mr speaker tory mps
were pretty happy at all of that
shouting the word more as boris johnson
sat down we've analyzed his language as
well the words that popped up in his
responses to the main questions you can
see the recovery the country his record
in government uh pop up a lot now
although kiyosama did not major on the
issue of parties in partygate he still
slipped in a few
word digs warning prime minister that's
not going to work with the police
the prime minister might want to sharpen
how he answers questions under interview
he's going to need it this prime
minister has no respect for decency or
honesty
and the labour leader even compared
boris johnson and rishi sunak to two
ill-fated characters in a 90s crime film
he and the chants are the tory felmer
and louise hand in hand as they drive
the country off the cliff and into the
abyss of low growth and high tax
i think the right honourable gentleman
is dick dastardly and
mutley
the pm did seem amused by one opposition
heckle as he discussed plans for the
queen's platinum jubilee
the whole house will want to join me in
thanking her majesty for her tireless
service we look forward to celebrating
her historic reign with a series of
national events in june mr speaker
this morning i had meetings
i had meetings with ministerial
colleagues there were no critical
conservatives this week but david davis
who has called for the prime minister to
quit did decide to sit next to fellow
rebel grantee andrew mitchell
there was no sign of leadership
favorites rishi sunak or liz truss
although the foreign secretary is of
course in covert isolation instead home
secretary pretty patel seemed to be
briefing the pm and heckling his critics
and record time uh mr speaker people in
work now than before the pandemic and do
you remember this man jonathan gullis
the enthusiastic tory mp who last week
went viral with his shouting and feet
banging in the chamber well today he was
told off by the speaker for his
continued rowdiness
mr gullis i think you've been trailed
for long enough and you don't want to be
thrilled anymore and that is the last
comment i have otherwise i will ring
your mother
now i watched all of today's pmqs from
the press gallery looking down on the
commons chamber and it was certainly far
calmer than in uh previous weeks a lot
of that anger and fury had been replaced
with as you saw humor and occasional
moments of derision one cabinet minister
claimed that he thought it was a net win
for the prime minister i'm not sure
there really was any clear winner but
certainly we saw certain economic
arguments road tested today that i'm
sure will reappear at the next general
election whether boris johnson is still
prime minister or not